The left-hand side of the equation is just y, and in place of y, we're
substituting in the y-coordinate at this point, which is 7. So, the left-hand
side should just become 7. The right-hand side, as we can see over here, has an
x in it. So, we need to substitute 3 into that spot. Simplifying that all the
way, gives us 4. Unfortunately, 7 is not equal to 4. In answer to the question,
are the sides equal, we have to say no. Since plugging in the coordinates this
point makes it so that the two side of our equation are no longer equal, which
we remember is the requirement of an equation, this point must not lay on this
line. In other words, these values for x and y do not satisfy the equation, y
equals 3x minus 5.